you
thirty-eight was that magic number
king of the cube got it alright let me
try the Sicilian this time I've been
going through some games recently for
enough for anything well yeah for me I
was playing both sides god I should say
going through games looking from white
and blacks perspective a lot of Sicilian
games some stuff with the dragon a lot
of stuff with the Scheveningen I was
that's the bulk of it actually the
shepherding and that small pawn Center
yeah let's let's try and work with that
actually it's still entered territory
such as this a lot of lines actually
with the g4 stuff g4 age 6 and that h4
stuff okay so we could still enter that
and now you have six g4 but I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do this a six move first let's
keep this useful move
keep those nights out of b5 so as is
typical on the black end against the
open Sicilian development will lag quite
a bit but these guys are tough to crack
possible ideas right f/4g for some
combination of those types of moves f3
even just to solidify this bishops
position and reinforce efore in
anticipation of the eventual think head
over the Queen Bishop putting pressure
on e4 and that's what we're having so I
need to look into this d5 break b5 first
I'm just night here about just a night
here b5 or night here doesn't really
matter sure them probably does but I
don't know the difference is so well do
I and Queen c7 how about that keeping
out Bishop here let me do that so not
the greatest thing to do moving that
Queen out so early but she has her
points I don't want this Bishop to play
to c4 and I'd have to maybe worry about
some issues with sacrifices on e6 with
both minor pieces converging on that
square not the case right now so let me
get my knight contributing I have a
close eye on c4 and so naive 5:2 that
Square and is my opponent really gonna
go Kings side I wonder about that I
think this is this is fine
let me do it let me do this there could
be some sacrifices on this square
especially when the rook is on d1 Knight
takes Knight takes getting three pawns
for the minor piece as a result having
three healthy past even though they're
still in their home squares three
healthy passed pawns on the Queen side
and when I see a three I'm already
thinking to myself white is not going to
Castle queenside let's see how well
let's see how accurate I am with that
statement maybe maybe a white will throw
the curve at me and say no I will still
cast a queen side and allow you to open
up the position with the b4 that's and
that's a reason not to go Queen side I
don't know how affected it how effective
it will be but again any pawn advance on
the side where your king is castled is
subject to these type of opening lines
and breaks with b4 so okay did I call
that or what okay all right so that that
is that is the correct way to go King
side castling I will be doing the same
and I will be throwing my rook here now
as my opponent really have thoughts of
sacrificing and
square they really do that I don't think
I would be so concerned about that
actually because at the end of it I
would get seat to things are a little
bit different aren't they
or a lot different I should say in these
um the sacrifices that I'm talking about
on b5 come about a little bits a little
bit sooner and when the King resides on
the Queen side where there's queenside
castling and the king would be on c1 in
defending against possible counter
counter moves such as Queen c2 stuff so
not here Knight takes pawn takes Knight
takes the queen could drop back to c8
Knight takes pawn Bishop takes pawn
Queen takes bishop and at the end of it
Queen takes pawn here might seem a
little bit scary
since my queen is running short on
squares but I think she would be just
fine
now my only question is do I play h6 to
prevent this pawn push or am i okay with
it I think I'm just okay with it and I'm
going to play my knight here or here I
want to get to c4 this is this is a very
weakening move because my Bishop is
bearing right down towards their Kings
side so if I could if I could break down
this structure he's gonna turn into a
monster he's a bishop right now but he
will be a beast soon enough if this is
not maintained this f3 e4 structure so
if I do this my knight is kicked quite
timely in fact maybe I should have been
considering this instead of my last move
I did this natural-looking Queen and
King side move but maybe d5 was more
accurate that that pawn break that I
emphasized I thought so much in the last
game analysis video I posted to youtube
not um I wasn't focused on this so so
much was i okay anyhow we're in a
different position we're at about two
minutes each 95 or 96 is my thought to
c4 does it really matter
I'm gonna go here just to avoid f4 with
tempo
I think f4 will still be played in order
to keep my knight on e5 I'm expecting g5
knight here and then f4 to make sure my
knight doesn't get into V 5 if I'm
allowed to have a knight on e5 and b6
then I will be able to get a knight to
see for playing b3 is highly committal
in very weakening so I think I might
voluntarily throw my knight back
actually now let me get my up working a
little bit I'm not sure okay I guess the
idea behind this is for some lateral
defense of these queenside pawns
anticipating maybe some pressure on c2
maybe it's also a way to regroup this
Bishop but honestly his number one role
is going to be to watch over c4 if a
knight is allowed to play here and stay
here it's going to create all sorts of
havoc on the cob on the Queen side here
for white so his job watch over c4 now
how does white make further progress
these these are the only things that I
see is potentially annoying
okay this rook is now opposite my king
is there going to be some crazy knight
move there might be let me let me
voluntarily run away I really again with
this move I want to get my Knight to c4
that's what I'm essentially saying with
this move I want to get 95 to c4 and now
this idea of b3 is just wrong right it's
blundering the knight less than one
minute for white I'm not sure what else
could be played I guess F for something
that comes to mind as soon as it's
replayed here I started to worry a bit
more about Knight sacrifices to this
square but since he's voluntarily going
away I don't have that concern I guess
with this move maybe Bishop here's the
intention to stop the knight from
jumping in here and now this is going to
be big trouble I think at least I I
thought it would be big trouble but
maybe it's not I could move this pawn no
I can't
Knight takes here Queen check and then
there's a knight block on d4 less than a
minute hmm I could take this pawn am i
doing i takes pawn here breaking down
this
I could still do that yes this is this
is the heart of the structure and he's
gone now this is the I referenced is
like the the K no the K no for you
Mortal Kombat freaks out there you know
what I'm talking about
the fatality of the queenside pawn
structure that's the heart and without
that these guys become very weak so c2
is hit oh and at the end of it
guess who's losing a piece no no no yes
I am could you make up your mind oh
there goes a [ __ ] I get a couple pawns
for it but that's no that's not good I
didn't I didn't think I didn't think far
enough ahead did I know I didn't
alright well I really like my dark
square Bishop I think it's a good thing
I have a time edge that's the only thing
I have because I'm down a minor piece
right now let me attack the knight in
this pond so I'm still able to put
pressure on my opponent and this is very
tempting but it's wrong Bishop c5 and
there's bad things happening in fact
bishops still here is winning because
now the King has to run to the corner
he'll be mate it's actually turning out
to be mate next but severe time pressure
towards the end there all right good
game king of the cube something tells me
this was not the first time that we
played against each other that name kind
of sticks out certain ones doing that
one's one of them let's go back yeah
that follow-up of a fork hitting my two
unprotected bishops I didn't I didn't
calculate through I didn't calculate
deep enough but maybe maybe it was still
okay it still would have been some work
and maybe I could quickly touch on
towards the end in that position even
why I chose to eat my dark square Bishop
instead of my light square bishop but
okay so we have this set up here which
is who is like the English attack setup
versus its open Sicilian and eighth free
I think what you really do have to be
booked up I'm certainly not but I know
that this is a good placement for my
pawns the small pond center the
queenside expansion the connecting of my
knights the bishop on b7 the roof NC
eight and we never really got to see
this g4 g5 stuff in action when it was
played I really didn't have as much
concern about it it seemed to happen at
a moment where it wasn't as critical for
me to be finding the correct
continuations and again with a three
that's my that's my cue to know white
isn't going to go Queen side and if they
do they're helping me out a great deal
even if this advance comes with the
sacrifice of a pond I'm breaking things
down I'm breaking down the white pawn
structure and the white King would
therefore become more accessible so
completing our development and now and
now old that here's the other thing you
know if you're playing a three and
you're not going to go Queen side but
rather Kings side this g4 g5 stuff now
makes your King more vulnerable so I
really do think that the way to go is is
this Queen side stuff but I'm far from
being booked up on these lines and I
don't really have a great deal to to
offer for you know where to go from
there like after after be for the knight
may very well have to run home if he's
going to a4 he's certainly accessible
I've seen both but I'm not sure of the
exact position I I don't know but we
have you going king side your rook is
playing here this pawn ISM is really
tough to get out for as long as I have
my bishop on e7 and the idea of trying
to maybe throw up
a minor piece adding more pressure on it
with the bishop is always seeming to
fail to e5 so the major piece pressure
on the d6 pawn is really never much of
an issue for black now one thing on my
end is I was saying it during the game
right now instead of maybe going with
the routine castle maybe right now is
where I should be considering this pawn
break of d5 doing it one move later
right now d5 I get kicked my knight runs
away and then you would have capture and
as a result I would be having to play
with an isolated deep on again I'm black
in this one I'd be playing with an
isolated daepung so maybe I should have
I should have at least considered d5
right here and it seems maybe a little
bit counterintuitive since I am not
fully developed my king is still
technically in the center and to be
willingly opening up the position with
d5 but nevertheless it is still worth
considering because one move later now
maybe I just can't get it in at all
although I still in prepping it with
this move with Knight b6
I do have more support for it yeah these
these are yeah this is a strictly
defensive move I don't have much fear of
this so really the the critical line is
when your king is in it located
elsewhere located on the Queen side I I
don't have those that same fear and the
these moves I'm spending again are
focused on throwing a Knight to c4 and
when he got there he ended up doing some
damage
bending took on b2 but as it turns out
this is actually not so great
now this was this was a bit trickier to
calculate because you did took take my
night we didn't have the structural
change and then this yeah so I I should
have been doing something different let
me look at it
a little bit more this is there's no way
out of this I'm losing one of these guys
why did I keep my dark square bishop
around well white is weak on the dark
squares I think that was one of the
things that I just subconsciously
thought about weaknesses on the dark
squares and I saw also okay I could be
taking this pawn but I found I thought
better homes were available to my bishop
and another thing again this is a
variation that I should probably be
avoiding all together but let's just say
just taking it for what it is right now
how do I deal with the situation I'm in
I like keeping him around for the other
reason that my opponent won't be able to
trade bishops and this is to my liking
because if I'm going to be down material
I don't want to be welcomed to I'm not
so welcome to more and more exchanges so
that's why I want to keep that dark
square Bishop around better Holmes more
weaknesses on the dark squares for white
and there won't be any light square
bishop for dark square Bishop exchange
and at this point we're really way down
on time I do have two pawns for the
bishop some rook activity and maybe at
the end of it I don't know if that's
best but I do have these two past pawns
and I don't know how easy it would be to
get at this guy but I probably should
have been able to do something better
because I think that black is the side
to be preferred here hmm oh here's
another one
I don't have to take b2 I could take a3
see that there's I was getting fancy
talking about keno and taking them that
middle upon the heart of the structure
but I can also take a three and after
the recapture then my queen is there to
take them
and then if there's Bishop takes Knight
it could be taking with the queen or
still the pond and I would probably take
with the pond not concerned about
doubled pawns there this actually helps
out my bishop if there would then be
rook here I would have again in that
position I'm trying to express with you
visually here is if at the end of it
there's rook d7 I would have rook c7
with my Queen still being on c3 and the
Queen both Queens still being on the
board there so at night takes 83 is
probably the better choice there but we
in turn time scramble mode at that point
all right good game king of the cube
you